i'm ethan i'm elizabeth and we are from
cheap old houses on hgtv and discovery
plus
[Music]
maybe our biggest mistake in the
beginning was that we didn't have a
business plan at all with this we just
threw our hearts into it and we did it
just because it was fun right but i
think what that showed us is that do
something fun because if it's fun for
you
it's going to be fun for a lot of people
probably and that's what makes something
snowball and catch on our greatest
mistake was failing at a lot of things
we tried before this we tried blogs for
this blogs about that feeds about this
and then finally we found the one that
caught on that other people were
interested in and we ran with it and if
we hadn't
necessarily failed at those others we
might not be where we are today
so the moment that we really realized
that this was something that was super
special was when someone texted us and
dm'd us and they said
this is the post that changed our life
and they bought a cheap old house that
was the most moving piece of sort of
when we realized that this was a thing
it was a wake-up call we i knew we were
doing the right thing we know hundreds
of people who have now saved cheap old
houses and purchased these without this
instagram feed i mean literally the
makeup artist at the drew barrymore show
literally said without being inspired by
you guys i wouldn't have bought this
cabin along a creek in the catskills
for more digital videos head to the
drewberrymore show.com